first thing you want to do is you want
to look at your function and you want to
analyze what they call the sign changes
okay so what are exactly how the sign
changes well it's where it changes from
positive to negative or negative to
positive so here you can see we've got
positive 3x to the fifth negative 2x to
the fourth and so on so I've written
down the signs but let's check to see
how many times it switches so positive
negative that's once negative positive
that's twice positive negative it's a
third time negative to negative it
doesn't change so that means we have a
three sign changes so what that tells us
is we go over to our positive negative
imaginary chart over here sometimes this
is called like a P and I chart and what
that tells us is we have a maximum of
three positive zeros now what does that
mean three positive zeros it means that
when you go to the right of the y-axis
over here it's going to cross that X act
x axis a maximum of three times right
now if we want to analyze the maximum
times that it crosses the x-axis over
here in the negative range okay to the
left of the y-axis what we do is we
replace X with negative X so let me go
ahead and do that for us here we've got
three times negative x to the fifth
minus two times negative x to the fourth
plus negative x cubed minus four times
negative X minus eight if we go back and
simplify we get negative 3x to the fifth
negative 2x to the fourth negative x
cubed positive 4x and negative eight so
we've got a negative negative negative
positive negative so here you can see
it's changing once twice so what that
tells us is that we have a maximum of
two negatives and then if we add across
here three plus two plus zero equals
five it should always add up to this
highest degree of the polynomial okay
five in this case now the other thing
that's interesting is that if the
coefficients of your polynomial are all
real meaning there's none that are
imaginary then what happens is if your
zeros come if you have any imaginary
zeros they come as conjugate pairs so
what that means is for example if we had
two imaginary zeros then what happens we
have to do
decrease the number of positive zeros by
two or the number of negative zeros by
two so we always go down by two four six
eight by an even number right even
amount because of these imaginary ones
coming in conjugate pairs so in this
case another possibilities we could have
one positive to negative and two
imaginary another possibility we can
have three positive zero negative and
two imaginary another possibility we
could have one positive zero negative
and four imaginary now I can't take
another two away from this one and make
this a negative one you can't have a
negative number of zeros so these are
our only combinations here now you're
probably asking yourself well Mario why
does this even matter right well here's
the thing if you're trying to use your
rational zero theorem to you know
calculate the zeros the P over Q method
you probably learned in your class what
you can do is you can be strategic you
can say well I know that there's at
least one positive zero if it's this
scenario here or here there might be no
negative zero so what you can do is you
can say well I might not want to check
over here for a negative zero first
because it might be these scenarios
where there's not any negative zeros so
I know there's at least one positive
zero let me see if I can find that one
first and so it just gives you a
starting point and sometimes helps you
to narrow down you know the
possibilities when you're going to check
for those a rational zero